[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a este programa de radio
francia internacional y de france 24 hoy
les hablamos de la historia de
ciudadanos europeos que se radicalizaron
y que emigraron a las tierras del
califato del grupo terrorista estado
islámico cuáles fueron sus motivaciones
para dejarlo todo e integrar un grupo
despiadado que sembró el pánico tanto en
siria en irak como en europa y lo
hacemos a través de un libro el infiel
que habita en mí hoy hace escala en
parís su autora la periodista española
pilar cebrián o pilar muchísimas gracias
por esta conexión desde madrid
muchas gracias a nosotros bueno pilar
cebrián es periodista especializada en
oriente medio' yihadismo ha trabajado
para varios medios de comunicación
cubriendo la zona y ahora publica este
libro en la editorial ariel un libro
apasionante que es un recorrido por las
biografías de seis personas mujeres y
hombres y a través de sus historias
intenta arrojar un poco de luz sobre sus
motivaciones y también sobre el espinoso
tema del retorno a sus países de origen
y del limbo legal en el que muchos se
encuentran el pilar el trabajo que ha
hecho con este libro es inmenso ha
viajado a varios países ha entrevistado
a los protagonistas en campamentos en
cárceles también a familiares y amigos
como ha sido todo este proceso
bueno este trabajo ha sido sin duda muy
revelador porque todo este proceso que
estabas ahora introduciendo no el
fenómeno de los occidentales se han
metido en el estado islámico bueno pues
parece tremendamente a anacrónico pero
en el fondo es profundamente
contemporáneo y explica pues cuáles son
algunos de los problemas o de los vacíos
o de las vulnerabilidades de la juventud
europea porque todos estos 5.000
europeos que se han unido a la vieja
sensibilidad pues la mayoría de ellos la
mayoría de mis entrevistados no llegaban
a tener 30 años entrevistado a hombres
de 21 de 28 de 27 mujeres de 16 años 21
entonces bueno es un fenómeno que
explica que hay algo en la sociedad
europea que no está funcionando
correctamente fue difícil por ejemplo
hablar
me acuerdo de uno de los personajes no
de los protagonistas del libro el
yihadista belga táriq cada uno en una
prisión en irak o hablar por ejemplo con
yolanda martínez de la española que está
encerrada en un campamento en siria
bueno el acceso claro que ha sido algo
complicado estamos hablando de la cuota
de prisioneros
de yihadistas más numerosa del mundo
pero también pues son unos presos de
máxima sensibilidad pues porque han
combatido en un territorio controlado
por una organización terrorista y bueno
pues lo que han conocido lo que han
descubierto es información que es
clasificada en controlada por los
servicios de inteligencia en irak fue
tremendamente difícil estuve tres meses
en bagdad
estableciendo contacto pues son
oficiales con políticos con todo tipo de
contactos iraquíes y me permitirán
llegar hasta las cárceles y al final no
conseguí y en siria es un proceso que
está digamos como más fijo los
periodistas pueden llegar hasta aquí a
hacer unas entrevistas con la
inteligencia militar kurda y a partir de
allí solicitas unas entrevistas en los
campamentos y
generalmente te dan ese acceso a unas
entrevistas en unas cabinas
prefabricadas con las mujeres que antes
estar acompañadas de sus hijos pero
bueno es algo complicado el acceso y sí
que ha sido ese acceso que ha
determinado un poco las historias 50 del
libro en función de los prisioneros a
los que he podido llegar así que los
perseguidos que han sido los personajes
de la publicación el libro comienza
justamente con la historia de yolanda
martínez una chica de una familia con
recursos que se enamora se casan con un
joven marroquí y los dos se radicalizan
en en madrid luego viajarán como muchos
otros a siri a través de turquía y el
rol de las mujeres en el califato era la
de dar a luz a hijos ella por ejemplo y
el anda tiene cuatro pero hay muchas que
tienen muchísimos hijos a su cargo no
sólo los hijos de esas mujeres sino a lo
mejor hijos de la primera mujer del
marido que los tienen ahora a su cuidado
cuál es la situación
que se encuentra a usted cuando llega al
campamento la situación de miles de
mujeres y de niños que están un poco
abandonados a su suerte y sin una
esperanza por el momento de salir no
claro el proceso en el que ellos se
encuentran ahora una vez que ha caído
del califato y ellos pasan a ser
prisioneros de guerra es no solamente un
tiempo judicial sino también es un inbox
de derecho porque ellos son detenidos
sin derechos es un tiempo diplomático no
hay conexión con los países que en un
principio se han negado en bloque a
traer a estas personas de vuelta a sus
países y también además hay un limbo de
las necesidades más básicas en el
sentido de que no hay atención sanitaria
los campamentos tampoco hay alimento
suficiente la organización mundial de
alimentos lo que reparte a estos
prisioneros en jalis estás son cajas en
las que hay pan aceite y alguna legumbre
como garbanzos pero los niños no están
teniendo acceso a carne pescado fruta y
eso ya lo ha dicho save the children que
va a generar una
generación que va a ser más bajita y con
problemas mentales son la situación que
hay en los campamentos es de absoluta
necesidad
y como cuento pues en un vacío legal
porque no se puede procesar a estos a
estos prisioneros que son extranjeros
los kurdos no pueden emitir sentencias
contra ellos los países de procedencia
en concreto los europeos no quieren
facilitar la vuelta ni tampoco suplir
las necesidades que estas personas
puedan tener en este estado de atención
y es como un lugar parado en el tiempo
estos campamentos en el libro escribe
justamente el limbo legal en el que se
erigen los centros de entrenamiento más
siniestros de nuestra era un limbo que
desconecta a la solución del problema a
los presos europeos de su nacionalidad y
que hace de la ratonera de siria al
escenario prototipo para contener a
cualquier precio la expansión del virus
de la yihad algunos países si han
accedido a repatriar a algunos de sus
ciudadanos otros no o europa se muestra
muy reticente y entre esos países tal
vez uno de los más reticentes sea
y usted lo vivió en una de las historias
que cuenta lo vivió en carne propia el
acompañar a unos una familia la familia
lópez una familia francesa que en el
rock quería ver a sus nietos y darles
medicinas cuadernos ya su nuera a esa
familia concretamente no la dejan entrar
y todo apunta que es porque es francesa
si efectivamente esto fue un viaje que
dijimos varios padres dejar estas
occidentales que querían visitar pues no
solamente a sus hijos sino terminan los
nietos a esos niños que sus hijos habían
tenido en el califato y que ellos
todavía no conocían los lópez fueron
unos de ellos además también había unos
austríacos
canadienses había una madre de suecia
pero la cuestión de los hombres fue la
más impactante porque ellos querían
entrar en el campamento para visitar a
la nuera es decir a la que se había
casado con su hijo leonardo pez y sobre
todo a todos a sus cuatro nietos dos de
ellos alienación francesa pero otros dos
habían nacido en siria en el califato
estuvimos haciendo todo el proceso para
lograr los permisos a las autoridades
militares
todas esas reuniones
los kurdos ellos siempre se han mostrado
favorables a que estos familiares
visiten a sus prisiones a sus hijos
prisioneros y hadise estás porque es una
manera de dar
un poco de visibilidad a este tema ya
que los kurdos quieren que estas
personas regresen a sus países de origen
y de esta manera conseguimos los
permisos un papel firmado en el que los
lópez tenían la acreditación para en
grande campamento y charlar durante una
hora con su 9 con sus niños fue en el
último momento cuando estábamos entrando
en el campamento de arroz cuando los
guardas solamente dejaron pasar a los
suecos ya los austriacos y pararon así
con la mano a los dos padres franceses y
se inventaron una excusa dijeron que era
porque la nuera no era el familiar
directo al final y observé por una de
las autoridades kurdas nos confesó que
era porque macro no había dado la orden
de que no se podía establecer ningún
contacto con los hija vistas francesas
el tema es muy sensible para francia
porque fue uno de los escenarios de los
atentados de yihadistas europeos que
habían estado en siria e irak y que
volvieron a cometer los los atentados
del 13 de noviembre hay uno de los
protagonistas del libro
que hablábamos antes tarija down que ha
tenido contacto él era como un mediático
no con las redes sociales el belga y
tuvo mucho contacto con yihadistas
europeos franceses que no pudieron
viajar al califato y que cometieron
atentados aquí él estuvo en contacto
esto podría explicar las reticencias de
parís a que hubiera contacto con esos
detenidos
sí
la reticencia de parís atiende a que
francia sí que es verdad que se ha
convertido un poco el epicentro de la
radicalización yihadista en europa es el
país europeo que uno de los principales
en el mundo en los demás
desplazados al califato ha habido cerca
de 2.000 personas en la diversidad e
irak además de que también francia es
pues uno de los objetivos y uno de los
países en los que más atentados ha
habido en los últimos años pero también
es una cuestión política al final
no solamente francia sino todos los
países europeos se han negado en bloque
a traer a estas personas de vuelta
porque saben que políticamente es una
estrategia nefasta
s traer esa imagen de unos vuelos de
repatriación en los que se está trayendo
de vuelta a los supervivientes del
estado islámico pues es una imagen que
va a tener unas consecuencias nefastas
que va a dar alas a la oposición que va
a provocar el auge de la extrema derecha
en todos los países de europa y es por
ello por lo que ningún gobierno ningún
líder europeo se atreve a bueno pues a
firmar la sentencia del fin de su
candidatura clara cebrián no tenemos más
tiempo el pilar que ha publicado este
libro ha sido este libro el infiel que
habita en mí muchísimas gracias
muchísimas horas a vosotros y ahora
todos ustedes también muchísimas gracias
por habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com bien france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]